en tunisie le parti islamiste ennahdha
dans le viseur un day watch ong
tunisienne annonce vouloir saisir la
justice à l'encontre de la première
formation politique du pays elle la
soupçonne de corruption et financements
occultes lors de ses campagnes de 2014
et 2019 les précisions de bassam chebbi
le parti ennahdha de nouveau dans la
tourmente en pleine crise partisane est
pointé du doigt par une large partie de
la population qui le rend responsables
de la crise politique et économique que
traverse le pays le parti de rached
ghannouchi réputé proche des frères
musulmans ne semble pas en avoir fini
avec les problèmes dans le viseur de
l'ol jay walsh spécialisée dans la lutte
contre la corruption en tunisie la
formation politique est accusé d'avoir
accepté des financements directs ou
indirects de sources inconnues et de
parties étrangères l'omg a fait savoir
qu'en plus de contrats de lobbying
conclu par le mouvement avant les
élections de 2014 et 2019 ennahda aurait
signé d'autres conventions avec la
société américaine burton master
spécialisé dans la communication et les
relations publiques une violation selon
les ong de la loi du 7 août 2015
relative à la lutte contre le
blanchiment d'argent je vous propose
d'écouter à m bedoui conseiller
juridique à watch organisation à ocz a
détecté deux contrats de lobbying au
profit du parti politique navx en date
2016 et 2018 donc d'un montant total
allant jusqu'à un million de dinars donc
juste il faut préciser que lobbying en
soi n'est pas condamné mais le problème
c'est doux le financement de ces
contrats donc on trouve pas la trace au
des traces de ses dépenses dans les
contrats financés au les rapports
financiers du parti navx et donc il faut
se demander d'où ce financement et quels
seront les impacts de ce financement
douteux sur l'intégrité des élections et
sur l'avis des électeurs on va porter
plainte pour tout dépassement de la loi
surtout la loi électorale qui condamne
et le décret loi de 2000 ans qui
organise les partis politiques qui
condamne tout tout financement douteux
est interdite
des financements étrangère et donc c'est
ça donc nous sommes en train réellement
de chercher tous preuve pour toute
preuve peu pour que assurer un certain
niveau de transparence de la vie
politique à ce jour aucune réaction du
parti islamiste face à ces accusations
alors que la question du financement des
partis politiques semble refaire surface
depuis l'opération mains propres lancée
par le président sayed le 25 juillet
dernier c'est la justice tunisienne
longtemps critiquée pour sa lenteur dans
les dossiers de corruption sera scrutée
par une large partie de la société
civile qui se bat à l'image de los
angels pour faire la lumière sur les
financements des partis politiques
tunisiens lundi le président sayyed
avait reçu au palais de carthage le
président du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature pour lui rappeler le retard
pris par la justice tunisienne pour
statuer sur les affaires de corruption